what started out as a 50 year old  challenge is now possible through  deepmind's latest Innovation Alpha fold  a deep learning algorithm that has  predicted nearly 214 million protein  structures up from the previously known  1 million that's 200 times it's  revolutionized the scientific Community  to help create life-saving treatments to  diseases like Chagas in fact these  predicted structures are available as a  part of the no-cost public data sets  program so that you can run custom  queries on bigquery and now you can run  Alpha fold reliably on your own by using  these available Solutions on vertex AI  you can try it out first using our  Solution on vertex AI workbench which  includes a python notebook and  containerized hosted environment to make  protein predictions using a limited  genetic database